let's escape speed light oh yeah I'm
rocket ship hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Emily
wants to play now I know it's been a
while since I played this game but v ah
de yada yada excuses excuses I was on
vacation some other [ __ ] I have no
goddamn idea so now we got the clown oh
dude I forget when his name is Bobo Fonz
oh hey whoa
goddamnit hello you're out here a little
early don't you think huh I'm scared
stare at utila you gooey cuz I remember
that's the strategy and also someone
mentioned that there might have been a
secret corridor somewhere over in the
bedroom area but I'm not gonna go look
for it until you go away okay there we
go okay so now that she's gone right
thank you
so convenient for you to do that for me
okay someone said that there was some
kind of secret do daddy over here or
something in the closet I can't exactly
remember I can't exactly remember what
it was but if I'm left oh my god didn't
you know that you don't know does that
mean doesn't mean I can go okay okay
cool all right thank you okay weird
weird noises someone said something was
some way it's been over a month now and
we still haven't
in the police yeah okay his move neither
body someone said that there was like a
secret border somewhere over here but
maybe I'm totally mistaken someone will
have to you know talk about that later
ever since we moved in Emily started
acting different no I think I know I
guess it really stressed her out okay
all righty then if everyone could just
calm down for a little bit I'd like to
see if I can get to the bottom of this
mystery huh oh hey let you go in here
floating in mid-air like that I sure
love your talents oh no you're not
floating your belly go away oh I know no
boy leave baby right now
oh god oh the children oh they're coming
in the back door oh okay all right
everything find it okay now that I've
officially thrashed my it's completely
and not gonna be able to speak properly
for the rest of this game oh don't say
still mmm okay so I can't tell if they
were moving out or moving in
I think they mentioned I'm just gonna go
whoa I was good I'm so glad I went in
there yeah well sounds like Wade when
he's deflated like where oh hey girl
there's some oak Oh smoke Oh Yoko Ono
how are you doing good day you know the
same too bad all I got to do is like not
move and keep an eye out for you I don't
even think I
wander around the house unless there's a
greater mystery that I need to solve
here which I don't think there might be
a year ago okay
I can't remember someone said no some
kind of like secret switch to go like
into some closet back area because
someone did confirm that every time you
go down into Emily's little area she
kills you dead which I could have
guessed from when from when I did from
when she killed me dead basically I
don't want to die again because I
actually want to progress through this
pretty well what's that by in there so
goddamn I could have sworn hi how's it
going how you doing are you good oh I
love what you've done with your hair
you know dip it in black tar and pure
evil that's nice also the dress great
very reminiscent of the ring and
nightmares that I've had in the past and
everything that I hate in life pretty
much you embody all the ugly features in
the back of my mind that I keep
suppressed so if you could just do like
I do it oh god oh hey hmm you better
yeah you better
I don't like that why has she not gone
away why the hell is she not gone away
maybe she didn't like what I was doing
about her oh god oh god god damn
Jesus she is active maybe towards the
end of the night I'm alone so you won't
be me well you might be me but you won't
be made you might be me you very much
might be me are you gone do I do how do
I know how do I know what I'm safe yeah
I know I'm safe
I escaped it wrong to keep it on I think
it is about six minutes claims to me
about six minutes which is pretty five
nights at freddys style
yeah another hour now I don't remember
how do I defeat the other one
what is he little Z guides don't run
from Chester okay so run from Chester
unless it's tricking me on this one and
I'm not supposed to do that hmm and the
secret stealthy sleuth pizza delivery
man ready to view to the bottom of this
mystery
nothing oh hi oh please don't turn on my
grundle mm-hmm
no don't fondle my balls please hmm
thank you that was very nice I guess
this secret detective meet the delivery
man doesn't materias if only there was a
way to get out of here Domino's oh I
mean I don't even exist
Oh oh god where why what'd I do oh my
god oh oh oh God what do I do
Oh God so I keep doors open Oh God
Oh like this well I got a runaway from
Chester keep these open please
oh hi how's it going there hi you did
huh come back here
it would've weird with you to see your
manager I don't like this okay
least Yoko doesn't see me touch Oh God
like five accusation I'm running as fast
my stubby little Asian
oh that's not fair that's not fair
that's not fair how was I supposed to
win I want to punch a surgery what about
you ask douchiness oh what a bunch of
deuce facie Oh what about your stupid
poop I don't like that I don't like that
much at all
all right let's try this again I imagine
because Chester did spawn so how the
hell was I supposed to be able to deal
with that that did not make sense
maybe I was supposed to stay in the same
room until he charged me and then then I
was supposed to run away cuz that could
have triggered it because when I went to
another room it seems like he appeared
in here
so I just got us I probably just got to
stay in between these rooms maybe just
stay over here wait okay hello dude well
that wasn't very far okay I can do that
I can deal I can deal with that gesture
okay fine
be a dick go away you don't want your
pizza either so I imagine if I just stay
over in this area I should be okay
doesn't seem too terribly bad so
apparently hi how you doing over there
nice but you know you could do a little
better on your makeup and your weird
grabby hands are a little too grabby for
my tastes where'd yoko go seems pretty
simple seems almost too simple seems too
simple for the sleuth a Domino's
detective I'm gonna get to the bottom of
this hmm [ __ ] you [ __ ] you that's right
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you hmm yeah you should be
disappointed to be disappointing a lot
of work public okay alrighty then so he
does I didn't know what's wrong way was
in at the moment but did
he just chases you out of room and then
closes turns the light off and that's
how you escape him and then it's easy it
seems like Yoko isn't a part of this
night or this hour the Dominos detective
too texted there might be some sinister
paranormal activity going on here hey
doing much care for it
all I know is I gotta get this pizza to
its owner or else everything will come
crumbling down in this wretched City and
then it'll look above me from the
rafters and all crying for help and I'll
say no maybe that I'll say 30 minutes or
your pizzas free this joke is bad anyway
Hey look at me look at me with all my
accomplishing muscles okay so I'm gonna
see what's going on
and then if it's too bad I don't know
what on you I don't know oh gosh I just
don't know
and seem so bad they seem to be turning
off and on the lights a little more what
is the message say isn't this so fun
yeah actually that's the first time you
told the truth
oh wait uh where is she where is she
where'd you go mmm
rich go oh oh hey you caught in the door
hey oh sorry
ah I must have closed that on you I'm
sorry is that uncomfortable I don't care
don't weigh now please go away go away
no leave leave now go away shoo
no oh God Oh God oh yeah that's right
get out of there hey think you're doing
oh-o-oh at least have some friends in
the basement oh okay cool thank you okay
so I don't want to go down in the
basement matter what that's like a
definite but this is like a door here so
there's got to be a way to open where oh
hey how's it going I'm gonna leave okay
goodbye
your deathtrap goodbye not [ __ ] oh god I
thought it moved okay we're fine okay
don't bother me don't bother me Oh
unless Chester hey hi how are you doing
are you okay
does he love me Oh God
oh okay that's how it's gonna be okay so
I made it tonight or our three so I'm
gonna continue this on in another
playthrough let me know in the comments
below what secrets I'm missing out again
because I know that I'm missing
something that someone said but I can't
remember what it was so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always little see you in the next video
oh there dorky hokum did you who will
get ready work alright for 30 seconds
I'll do it again